[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce moment des changes
à l'occasion de cette journée
internationale des droits des femmes
nous sommes très heureux de vous
retrouver ici depuis le siège des
républicains vous avez été très nombreux
plus de milliers à nous poser de
nombreuses questions
les questions qui vont être opposés à
chacune de mes collègues que j'ai le
plaisir d'avoir autour de moi et que je
vais vous présenter aujourd'hui c'est un
homme qui va faire l'animation c'est moi
qui vais passer la parole qui vais poser
des questions et ce sont nos femmes de
talent d'énergie de conviction qui vont
apporter leurs réponses
c'est un moment important pour nous
notre famille politique
même si on l'a peut-être parfois
oubliées a toujours été beaucoup pas
engagé sur la protection des droits des
femmes
historiquement depuis une des grandes
lois majeures de la république celle
portée par simone veil la loi pour liv
et g c'est une des premières grandes
lois de protection des femmes au sein de
la république on n'a pas oublié et c'est
simone veil jacques chirac et toutes
celles et ceux qui ont combattu pour
cette belle évolution dont nous sommes
les héritiers politiques aujourd'hui
et puis de nombreuses lois successives à
la fois pour l'émancipation des femmes
pour qu'elles trouvent leur place toute
leur place dans notre société dans les
post la décision en politique aussi le
chemin est long mais nous progressons et
c'est une ambition que nous voulions
avoir aujourd'hui et puis des lois plus
récentes
ok le mes collègues ont d'ailleurs
participé quel j'ai eu le bonheur de
participer aussi pour protéger les
femmes victimes de violences le bracelet
anti rapprochement la généralisation du
bracelet anti rapprochement
l'accélération des mesures d'ordonnancé
de protection la protection des femmes
de leur logement de leurs enfants
toutes ces mesures elles ont été votées
par les républicains ils viennent d'une
loi portée par les républicains aient
voté à l'unanimité
on ne pouvait pas commencer cet échange
sans rappeler l'héritage historique qui
est le nôtre et vous dire que si nous
avons cet instant des changes c'est
parce que ce combat pour la place des
femmes pour la protection des femmes
pour leur émancipation est non seulement
un combat qui nous touche ici chez les
républicains
mais un combat d'avenir pour notre pays
et pour en parler plus en détail
j'ai autour de moi trois de mes
collègues valérie bassin malgras qui est
vice présidente des républicains député
de l'aube
alexandra morquio forte à fond d'un
pardon qu'est ce que t'as générale
adjointe des républicains et sénatrice
des alpes maritimes qui était aussi
membre du haut conseil
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
elles à chalk sénatrice du bas-rhin qui
nous entoure et annie genevard qui va
nous rejoindre dans quelques instants
je propose qu'on commence dès à présent
par les questions que nos internautes
ont pu vous poser je vais vous les
répartir vous allez chacune y répondre
pour cette première question elle vous
est destiné à vous quatre c'est une
question de marie-christine de saint
sernin quels sont vos parcours scolaire
comment est née votre intérêt pour la
politique et combien de temps vous at-il
fallu pour être élu vous les femmes qui
aujourd'hui formé notre famille
politique
la première réponse valérie bonsoir à
tous
bonsoir à tous je suis ravi de te
retrouver sa aurélien et mes chers
collègues bien sûr également faire
participer les droits des femmes
alors mon parcours scolaire comment est
né mon intérêt pour la politique d'un
parcours scolaire tout simplement alors
je suis auboise je suis toujours resté
dans le département moi j'ai fait de la
petite école jusqu'à mon bac +2 ou j'ai
fait un bac 1 bac dans la comptabilité
gestion et ensuite j'ai fait un dut de
commerce
j'avais les parents commerçants j'aimais
bien commerce et je me suis lancée
ensuite très rapidement dans une cale à
une carrière de commerçante dans
département où j'ai progressé et c'est
tout naturellement en progressant dans
activité professionnelle ou je suis
devenue présidente d'un grand groupe de
commerçants ou françois baroin que vous
connaissez tout seul en suisse certaines
m'a repéré et m'a demandé d'intégrer son
conseil municipal en 2014
donc c'est ce que j'ai fait nous avons
été élus bien sûr et très rapidement
françois a découvert ma personnalité mon
attachement pour ma ville et pour les
gens qui habitent et m'a proposé très
vite de me lancer aux législatives
et c'est comme ça que j'ai été élu j'ai
fait un mois deux formats n'y tambour
battant
mon suppléant était le député sortant 78
ans il a décidé d'arrêter après les
maquereaux
et voilà j'ai été élu et depuis c'est
une passion et un réel intérêt pour moi
de servir mes concitoyens et la france
bien sûr
alexandra bonsoir à tous et merci pour
pour ceux qui nous rejoignent et qui
suivent ce débat ce soir merci à notre
famille politique de consacrer un vrai
temps des changes ces thématiques qui
sont combien importante pour ma part
j'ai fait des études de journalisme
puisque j'ai été journaliste pendant une
dizaine d'années et c'est ce métier qui
m'a conduit en fait à finalement basculé
dans la politique en essayant à la chose
publique
donc en 2008 monsieur engagé en tant que
conseillère municipale en 2015 je suis
devenue conseillère départementale
et puis en 2020 donc assez récemment
j'ai eu l'honneur donc de me présenter
aux élections sénatoriales et depuis le
1er octobre donc je siège au palais du
luxembourg
bonsoir à toutes et à tous merci
effectivement aurélien d'organiser ce
temps des changes
je crois que c'est essentiel pour notre
famille politique d'avoir ce temps on
sait que le combat a lieu effectivement
le 8 mars mais également tout au long de
l'année alors pour ma part donc je suis
strasbourgeoise je suis sénatrice du
bas-rhin et j'ai commencé en fait en
politique très jeune j'étais investi au
conseil municipal
au niveau de la ville de strasbourg et
de fil en aiguille j'ai souhaité en fait
m'engager et j'ai pris ma carte à
l'époque à l'ump au moment où on fait
des blocages contre le cpe donc c'était
le contrat première embauche et j'en
avais tout simplement marre que ma fac
soit soit bloqué donc j'ai fait
finalement le choix de pouvoir en fait
m'investir de pouvoir prendre une carte
et un engagement au sein du parti
politique et au fur et à mesure le parti
m'a fait confiance m'a donné des
responsabilités notamment grâce à des
élus qui m'ont épaulé qui m'ont soutenu
aussi dans ma démarche et donc je j'ai
adhéré en 2006 et en 2014 je suis élu
pour la première fois à la ville de
strasbourg dans l'opposition quelques
temps après et conseillère régionale
d'alsace en 2016 je suis devenu
présidente de la région grand est et
comme alexandra depuis récemment depuis
octobre donc sénatrice du bas-rhin et
conseillère municipale de strasbourg
aura le plaisir d'accueillir annie
genevard notre président du conseil
national vice président de l'assemblée
nationale et député du doubs qui va elle
aussi vous retracer son parcours
merci merci chers aurélia bonsoir à tous
merci de nous suivre sur facebook live
alors moi mon parcours est assez
classique en ce sens que j'ai commencé
j'ai été recruté sur profil pour
appartenir à une liste ou aux élections
municipales chargées de la culture parce
que je m'intéressais aux questions de
culture
et puis le mandat suivant je suis devenu
maire je suis devenu sous ce même
mandats conseiller régional comme elsa
et puis présidente d'un pays ce qu'on
appelait les pays au sens de la loi
pasqua du terme et le mandat d'après
assez naturellement j'ai été investi
pour les élections législatives donc je
dirais qu'en en disant j'ai vécu tous
ses mandats
le mandat local le mandat territorial le
mandat national
après avoir été formé à tout autre chose
puisque j'ai une formation universitaire
classique en en lettres en littérature
et en histoire de l'art ça c'est pour la
partie je dirais livresque de la chose
mais pour le reste j'ai reçu une
formation familiale qui m'a prédisposait
à être proche des milieux économiques
papa était artisan et
l'ag pendant mes vacances nous nous
travaillons dans la l'entreprise
familiale donc j'ai à la fois cette
double formation une formation
intellectuels universitaires et puis en
même temps l'école de la vie qui était
qui est à mon sens un complément
indispensable
voilà donc j'ai arrêté de travailler
pour pouvoir exercer à plein de temps
mais mandat parce que pour une femme
on l'abordera peut-être mais c'est quand
même difficile de concilier toutes ses
implications de femmes et donc c'est un
choix que j'ai fait que j'ai fait
difficilement mais que je ne regrette
pas car comme l'a dit valérie
l'engagement public est un engagement
merveilleux qui offre des joies et des
perspectives qui sont irremplaçables
donc voilà c'est un choix de coeur que
que je ne regrette pas d'avoir fait
merci à tout c'est précisément la
question d'une de nos adhérentes and de
lyon qui va vous interroger sur la
manière dont vous organisez votre rythme
de vie est ce que vous arrivez à tout
concilier on sait que la vie d'une femme
le rythme de vie d'une femme n'est pas
exactement le même dans des obligations
vous pouvez avoir qui sont celles de
notre société
comment vous arrivez à les concilier
avec votre mandat d'élu est ce que vous
inspirer d'autres pays du monde qui
peut-être sont plus en avance que nous
je pense à l'europe du nord notamment
sur eux sur ces questions là pour
chacune d'entre vous ayez déjà devoir a
fait la transition parfaite
comment est ce que vous vivez ça
alexandra alors je crois que c'est
important
en fait de pouvoir
allier une vie professionnelle
c'est-à-dire politique pour nous et en
même temps une vie personnelle la vie de
famille je crois que quand on a la
chance voilà d'avoir un socle là il faut
s'appuyer dessus et ça doit rester la
priorité malgré l'engagement de chacun
d'entre nous dans la politique et
l'intérêt qu'on porte à ce travail je
pense que c'est important d'avoir des
moments pour soi qu'il soit en famille
ou ont des hobbies donc je pense juste
qu'il faut être méthodique et qu'il faut
que justement garder les pieds sur terre
et avoir une vie entre guillemets normal
les parlementaires sont des gens comme
les autres
on va chercher nos enfants à l'école on
va faire nos courses enfin il faut pas
imaginer qu'on vit dans une bulle et
qu'on est complètement déconnecté de la
vie de terrain et je crois que c'est ça
l'important en fait de rester connecté
d'avoir une vie comme tout le monde
oui on travaille au palais du bonbon au
palais du luxembourg
mais ça n'empêche pas que c'est le fait
justement d'être connecté et de
s'imposer en fait des bons temps normaux
comme mais c'est madame tout le monde
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on reste au plus
proche des préoccupations des français
oui je croyais comme alexandra que le
point important c'est effectivement une
une bonne organisation avant avant toute
chose et que cette conciliation
si difficile parce qu'elle est difficile
une conciliation entre la vie familiale
la vie professionnelle la vie politique
c'est finalement là aussi un combat un
combat de tous les jours et je peux le
mesurer aux regards effectivement de mon
mandat de sénatrice mais également dans
ma profession en fait d'avocate où j'ai
fait le choix du rang en fait mon
engagement politique de toujours
poursuivre à la fois mes études mais
également de pouvoir continuer mon
métier et je mesure à quel point c'est
par moment effectivement compliqué mais
à quel point c'est également
indispensable de pouvoir avoir cette
conciliation là et comme le disait très
justement alexandra c'est essentiel
d'avoir aussi des des moments de liberté
des soupapes de liberté évidemment avec
la stabilité familiale le fait d'avoir
ce socle qui est indispensable et aussi
de pouvoir tout simplement vivre des
moments à la fois
de loisirs et d'avoir effectivement
comme c'est le cas des des moments à soi
de liberté ça permet aussi de prendre du
recul sur nos missions de tous les jours
sur également le rôle qui est le nôtre
en tant que législateur de pouvoir avoir
ces temps de recul pour pouvoir
également faire notre mission au mieux
alors pour ma part je rejoins évidemment
ce qu'on dit mes collègues c'est vrai
que concilier sa vie sa vie d'élu sa vie
de parlementaire avec sa vie de femme de
mère d'épousé
c'est pas toujours évident donc il faut
privilégier une chose pour ma part je
pense que vous le partagez aussi c'est
privilégier sa famille la famille c'est
important voir grandir ses enfants les
aider à évoluer dans la vie c'est
important on est élus élus de la
république grands élus puisque ce soir
nous sommes tous des parlementaires sur
ce plateau mais on a une une vie de
famille vraiment à respecter et quand je
vous dis aider à faire grandir ses
enfants c'est important donc on doit
tout concilier une femme une mère une
épouse c'est aussi souvent la personne
qui fait tourner la maison on va dire au
niveau de l'intendance
malheureusement voilà tu le disais
alexandra on fait nos courses on fait
tout on a des époux qui travaillent eux
aussi donc il faut concilier tous à être
disponible pour que la maison puisse
tournées comme auparavant
c'est vrai qu'être parlementaire c'est
j'irai une pause dans sa vie
professionnelle pour ma part j'ai un
contrat de travail dans une grande
entreprise
je peux retourner travailler lorsque
j'aurai fini donc pour je le vis comme
une parenthèse formidable dans ma vie
professionnelle
donc on s'investit à fond mais ne pas
négliger sa famille donc ça demande
énormément d'organisation auprès de ses
enfants auprès de son mari auprès des
gens qui nous attendent aussi sur le
terrain parce qu on est énormément
sollicités bien sûr moi j'ai fait le
pari d'aller beaucoup sur le terrain
beaucoup à l'assemblée nationale donc il
faut réussir à concilier tout ça et je
crois que va les femmes on n'y arrive
vraiment bien parce que il faut faire
preuve d'organisation
je crois qu on le démontre dans notre
vie de tous les jours voilà donc
organisation toujours de plus en plus
[Musique]
c'est un sport redoutable nous sommes
des sportifs de haut niveau il faut
effectivement une des premières qualités
je crois pour faire la politique c'est
avoir une santé à toute épreuve parce
que les nuits sont courtes les journées
ils sont extrêmement chargé et
l'organisation ne souffre aucune je
dirais pour karaté parce que des qui a
raté tous tous s'en ressent et c'est
vrai que nous sommes toujours
extrêmement partagées entre le souci de
s'occuper de ceux qui nous sont chers
nos enfants notre famille nos amis
pouvoir se réserver un tout petit temps
de respiration de temps en temps pour
pour lire pour voir un bon film pour
passer une soirée des amis parce que
c'est quand même le sel de la vie et en
même temps travailler beaucoup
travailler toujours travailler à paris
travaillé en circonscription travailler
quand on est dans les transports quand
on est dans une salle d'attentes
on dit que les femmes ont l'habitude de
faire plusieurs choses en même temps
mais nous n'échappons pas à la règle
nous faisons beaucoup de choses en même
temps mais
ça donne ça donne beaucoup d'énergie
aussi parce que on ne s'endort pas on
est toujours à fond et je pense qu'il ya
une dynamique dans nos vies qui c'est
qui s'est installée et et qui est très
d'une part très enrichissante mais mais
aussi très motivante
bien sûr quelques fois il ya un peu de
fatigue mais voilà comme dans toute vie
je dirais dans toute vie professionnelle
ce que je décris là au fond n'est pas
très différent de ce que vivent la
plupart des femmes dans notre pays on
continue avec une question de princesse
de la symphonie qui est adressé à elsa
comment vivez vous vos relations avec
vos homologues masculins toute famille
pour les types confondus
alors merci à princesse de la seine
saint denis pour pour la question je
dirai en fait que je vis mes relations
avec mes homologues masculins comme
finalement avec mes homologues féminins
parce que je ne n'avais pts pas en
fonction en fait des interlocuteurs je
vais enlever le masque c'est une
habitude qu'il peut prendre
et effectivement je m'adapte jeu
n'adapte pas en fonction de
l'interlocuteur par contre je pense que
on se met par moment peut-être davantage
en fait tout simplement de pression lors
de réunions avec toujours ce même sujet
est ce que je serais assez compétente
est-ce que je suis légitime est ce que
finalement je dois intervenir est ce que
je dois prendre la parole
est ce que finalement je dois m'imposer
donc c'est toutes ces questions que
peut-être on se pose peut être un peu
plus et pour lesquels finalement il y à
ce besoin en fait d'accompagner et on le
voit bien les femmes ajustements aux et
à pouvoir s'affirmer mais également
avoir tout simplement confiance en elle
une question de marion de bordeaux ne
pensez-vous pas que encore aujourd'hui
en politique les femmes s'excusent
d'exister et craignent d'aller au combat
face aux hommes par crainte d'être jugé
que pour leur féminité on va laisser
valérie et alexandra nous apporter leurs
réponses
alors moi je m'excuse pas d'être une
femme en politique et j'ai pas de soucis
avec mes collègues hommes
voilà je je trouve que c'est pas un
problème lorsqu'on est une femme on on
s'empare des sujets on travaille on fait
on prend nos marques alors peut-être
plus avec plus de délinquants d'homme on
s'impose peut-être un petit peu moins
mais en tout cas pour moi ça n'a jamais
été un problème je prends les sujets je
m'en emparer puis on avance on déroule à
notre rythme
moi je ne vois pas vraiment la
concurrence avec les hommes pour moi ça
n'a jamais été un problème c'est parce
que tu en penses toi alexandra donc sur
cette question je voulais rebondir sur
les propos justement d'un collègue
elsa où c'est vrai que même si nous ici
autour de la table on a réussi en tout
cas à ne pas s'autocensurer et à se
lancer dans l'arène politique à défendre
nos convictions
je crois que c'est pas le cas encore de
toutes les élus de france il ya beaucoup
de femmes qui n'ose pas encore se lancer
en politique accepté d'être sur une
liste des municipales dans la ruralité
ou dans les grandes villes
donc il ya quand même clairement cette
question beaucoup de sondages sont parus
où on a interrogé les femmes en
justement sur cette question
de l'autocensure de se sentir de ceux de
se culpabiliser de se sentir capable de
est-ce qu'on va être à la hauteur qui se
pose aussi dans beaucoup de métiers dits
masculins c'est pas uniquement dans la
politique en tout cas nous on est la
preuve vivante qu'on peut avoir une
carrière politique
avoir un engagement au niveau de son
pays tout en en combinant avec une
activité professionnelle
une vie de famille et une vie surtout
équilibrés et épanouie et si je peux
ajouter quelque chose
est ce que tu dit alexandra souvent est
ce que je remarque parfois des femmes
souhaiteraient peut-être s'investir mais
nous pas pensent qu'elles ne seront pas
à la hauteur moi c'est un peu dans mon
caractère de ne pas faire attention à ce
qui se raconte et de fond c'est quoi
donc ce que je pourrais dire aujourd'hui
c'est d'encourager les femmes à foncer
et pas s'occuper de ce qu'on peut penser
ce que peuvent penser les autres et est
forcément des préjugés que certains
peuvent avoir oui pour la féminité pour
chez pas quoi c'est pas grave on est
déterminés on y va et et voilà comment
je dirais aux femmes qu'il faut faire
dans la vie politique
on continue avec une question de jade de
paris comment s'imposer enfin ce que
vous avez pu venir d'ailleurs à
l'instant et est-ce que c'est difficile
de se faire une place en politique quand
on est une femme annie peut-être avec le
parcours qui est le tien tu peux nous
éclairer alors pour moi les choses ont
été assez fascinant su sens que je n'ai
jamais ressenti de la part d'aucun de
mes collègues masculins
le l'idée que je serai
pas à ma place ou que les mandats que
j'ai pu exercer n'était pas légitime
mais ça a pris
ça a pris ça veut dire déjà beaucoup de
travail et parce que toutes les femmes
qui s'engagent en politique vous le
diront pour ne pas être prise en défaut
c'est ce côté un peu bon élève qu'ont
les femmes en politique elles veulent
être irréprochable et donc elle
travaille beaucoup et quelquefois elles
ont tellement peur de mal faire que ça
peut effectivement les les freiner voilà
donc je pense que elle travaille
beaucoup et à titre personnel c'est dans
ma nature moi j'ai toujours beaucoup
travaillé ou quelle que soit l'activité
que j'ai exercées donc ça n'a pas été
une difficulté pour moi pour le mandat
municipal aucune difficulté le mandat
régional non plus le mandat national
c'est amanda d'une autre nature c'est un
mandat beaucoup plus politique ou là il
faut s'imposer véritablement on va pas
venir vous chercher un donc les
responsabilités si vous voulez les
exercer il faut
il faut s'imposer et c'est une chose que
les femmes ont parfois des difficultés à
faire c'est un peu le le barrage
intérieur qui est le leur c'est parce
qu'elles sont toujours dans
l'interrogation de ce qu'est leur
légitimité
oui les femmes sont très légitimes pour
exercer les fonctions politiques qu'ils
exercent et il faut qu'il s'en persuade
on continue avec une question de lilian
de saint malo
ne pensez vous pas que le féminisme de
troisième génération qui s'attaque aux
questions notamment d'écriture inclusive
et à notre problématique que lilian
considère comme secondaire auraient
tendance à détourner le débat des vraies
problématiques qui touchent les femmes
pensent à l'égalité salariale aux abus
physiques à la protection et c'est sur
ce combat du féminisme qui est peut-être
s'intéresse à l'accessoire est plus tout
à fait à l'essentiel on va laisser elsa
vous apporter une réponse oui alors
merci
lilian de saint malo pour cette question
j'en profite aussi pour remercier annie
d'avoir finalement posé cette question
de l'écriture en fait inclusive et de la
pertinence en fait de cette écriture qui
finalement est une mauvaise solution à
une bonne question qui est finalement
comment on fait pour permettre à des
femmes de rentrer dans des métiers de
voir que certains métiers leurs sons
leur sont accessibles mais on voit les
dérives de l'écriture inclusive
on voit les difficultés que cela pose et
finalement cela ne m'aide pas le combat
de l'égalité femmes-hommes bien au
contraire je pense à titre personnel que
ça le dessert
et finalement on et résout pas les vrais
problèmes en fait de fond et je crois
que ce qui est essentiel dans le combat
qui nous anime toutes et tous ce soir
c'est de savoir par exemple comment on
fait pour qu en matière d'orientation
professionnelle en matière d'orientation
des jeunes pour pouvoir aiguiller au
mieux et faire en sorte que finalement
chaque métier puisse correspondre en
fait à des personnes quel que soit
finalement leur sexe mais en fonction de
leurs aspirations et de leur volonté
on a vu apparaître ce débat de
l'écriture inclusive
parce que de plus en plus de textes s'y
prête
on le voit et je le voit notamment à
strasbourg au niveau du conseil
municipal on a vu également d'autres
débats comme celui de des genres et les
cours de récréation et là aussi on voit
que l'on marche sur la tête alors que
finalement les questions elles sont
fondamentales on le voit sur la question
de l'égalité salariale qui est un vrai
sujet et qui reste d'actualité puisque
on voit que l'écart est encore beaucoup
trop important et totalement
incompréhensible mais également toutes
les violences inacceptables à la fois
sexistes et sexuelles
merci beaucoup à la une question de
canto de colmar qui touche à la fois la
question de l'accompagnement des femmes
mais aussi à la question de la précarité
des moments que nous traversons dans
notre pays cela m'attriste que les
tampons les serviettes hygiéniques et
les moyens de contraception ne soit pas
gratuit encore en 2021 c'est vrai pour
certains de ces produits là mais pas
pour tous est-ce que nous travaillons au
sein de familles politiques sur sur ces
questions à la fois de précarité et de
protection des femmes
alexandra oui alors c'est un sujet la
précarité menstruel notamment
qui mobilise beaucoup notre intérêt au
sein de notre famille politique le
président de la république souhaitait
avec son ministère a tâché abordé le
sujet il ya eu beaucoup d'effets
d'annoncés très peu d'action j'ai été
auditionné dans ce cadre là il ya 18
mois et aucune avancée n'a été fait en
tout cas des mesures elles existent par
exemple dans ma région sud la région
expériment on va expérimenter dans un
lycée est également dans mon département
des alpes maritimes dans des collèges la
distribution justement de serviettes
hygiéniques je crois qu'il faut en
parler le sujet n'est absolument pas
tabou je partage également cette même
question moi aussi je suis attristé
aujourd'hui que en 2021 on est encore à
répondre à cette question il faut
impérativement que ce soit c'est un
produit de première nécessité il doit
distribuer au même titre que le papier
hygiénique mais dans l'établissement
scolaire parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
familles où on ne parle pas encore des
menstruations donc il ya pas tout le
monde qui a encore un véritable accès à
ces moyens de protection mais dans
d'autres lieux je parle notamment dans
les hôtels par exemple on voit
facilement des rasoirs pour les monsieur
d enfin tout un tas d'outils et de
services proposés dans les chambres
d'hôtel mais très rarement de serre et
hygiénique je m'interroge pourquoi voilà
je pense que le sujet un peu tabou et
qu'il est vrai véritablement le temps de
lever le sujet là dessus et notre
famille politique en tout cas est
mobilisé plus que jamais pour apporter
des solutions
merci alexandra et on connaît en effet
dans ton implication forte sur sur ces
sujets la question suivante est celle de
béatrice de vaires sur marne
quand mettrons-nous en application la
loi qui donne le droit aux femmes de
rester dans leur logement
lorsqu il y a maltraitance de la part du
conjoint et pourquoi les procédures à la
rencontre des conjoints violents sont
elles toujours aussi longue c'est un
sujet essentiel ami tu peux nous
apporter des éclairages oui merci
béatrice pour cette question c'est un
sujet qui nous préoccupe beaucoup
la question de la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes d'ailleurs
je salue le travail qui a été fait par
aurélien pradié qui a fait voter une loi
pour le le port du bracelet anti
rapprochement pour les conjoints
violents
alors c'est une question quand j'étais
maire moi j'ai mis en place un
appartement de pour pour mettre à l'abri
les femmes et leurs enfants lorsqu'elle
était lorsque ceux ci étaient victimes
de violences intrafamiliales
c'est vrai que la justice voudrait que
ce ne soit pas la victime ou les
victimes si les enfants le sont
également
qu'ils soient obligés quitté le domicile
conjugal mais quelquefois il ya une
question de d'urgence absolue qui fait
que la femme et les enfants doivent
quitter le domicile au plus vite et que
voilà c'est dans ce sens là que se font
les choses mais ça n'est pas juste et du
reste un procureur je me souviens avait
fait en sorte que ce soit le conjoint
violent qu'ils soient évincés de
l'appartement
ce serait juste ce serait logique mais
malheureusement c'est souvent l'un vers
ce parce que
et bien parce que l'urgence commande
qu'on fasse qu'on éloigne la victime de
son agresseur alors qu'il faudrait
éloigné l'agresseur de sa victime
et c'est cette inversion à laquelle il
faudra que nous parvenions parce que
c'est le sens de la justice et c'est un
travail qui pourtant c'est un sujet qui
est pointé depuis longtemps et
malheureusement nous n'avons pas encore
suffisamment progressé mais je crois
beaucoup à l'engagement des maires dans
le combat qui est mené pour lutter
contre les violences au sein de la
famille je crois beaucoup à l'engagement
des conseils départementaux parce que
c'est aussi dans l'eure dans leurs
attributions et puis elle travail
parlementaire que nous faisons et je ne
désespère pas qu'un jour nous y
arriverons
mais vous avez raison de souligner que
tout ça prend beaucoup trop de temps on
est très fort en france pour les
constats on est beaucoup plus mauvais
pour les réponses apportées au constat
que chacun peut être amené à faire
merci beaucoup a ni une information
complémentaire
grâce à l'implication de notre famille
politique et au vote de la loi dont
annie parler qui est entrée en vigueur
au 1er janvier 2020 qui a été porté par
les républicains voté à l'unanimité de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
deux évolutions majeures au delà du
bracelet anti rapprochement
d'abord la réduction du délai
d'attribution des ordonnances de
protection qui sont ces outils qui
permettent de protéger les femmes
rapidement on était à plus de 30 jours
jusqu'ici de délai de délivrance et dans
la loi on a inscrit le fait que le délai
ne devait pas dépasser cinq jours ce qui
est aujourd'hui le cas dans les
applications qu'on a pu vérifier donc ça
ne suffit évidemment pas encore mais
c'est une très belle évolution que nous
devons à l'engagement notre famille
politique et enfin dans cette loi est
bien inscrit que désormais c'est le mari
violent qui doit quitter le logement et
la femme victime qui doit rester dans
son logement avec une prise en charge
des loyers notamment mais c'est
important de rappeler que toutes ces
progressions elles sont issues de notre
famille politique est pas pas des
opérations de communication de marlène
schiappa et
et ses amis une question d'alexandre de
l'ermitage quelle place accordez-vous à
la pédagogie pour lutter contre le
sexisme et quelles mesures éducatives
proposez vous pour lutter contre les
agressions sexistes
alexandra et elsa alors faut savoir
qu'on ne naît pas sexiste mais on le
devient et je pense que pour lutter
justement contre les dérives du sexisme
et il faut traiter le sujet dès le plus
jeune âge il ya des initiatives qui
peuvent être mis en place dans ma
commune d'antibes juan les pins on a
fait le choix de prévenir le sexisme aux
collégiens de 3e c'était un âge assez
mûr pour comprendre et il n'était pas
assez grand il avait l'âge en tout cas
pour pour pouvoir déconstruire certains
stéréotypes donc la pédagogie elle se
fait auprès des jeunes par le théâtre il
ya beaucoup de support et de et de
moyens différents pour faire passer des
messages mais ça un agent tout cas où
c'est pertinent chez eux et donc dans le
milieu professionnel aussi c'est
important dans le privé ou dans le
public il ya énormément de formation
maintenant sur ces sujets là alors là
aussi on peut le faire aussi par
différentes scènes a mimé à jouer mais
qui permet vraiment de décoincer de
sensibiliser et de ne plus être victimes
parce qu'il ya des personnes aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont vraiment victime de sexisme
et puis pour aller plus loin aussi après
le sexisme on peut arriver aussi
malheureusement sur les violences faites
aux femmes donc de prévenir en tout cas
le séisme notamment auprès des jeunes
c'est un bon moyen aussi en espérant que
ça puisse porter ses fruits et et
prévenir certains futur comportement
violent oui alors pour pour compléter
effectivement je crois que à la fois
l'éducation mais également
l'apprentissage est un élément essentiel
dans la lutte contre le sexisme et comme
le disait alexandra dès le plus jeune
âge et on voit qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'initiatives d'actions qui sont
portés par les collectivités et les
collectivités territoriales
pour exemple dans ma région il y à une
opération qui a vu le jour qui s'appelle
le mois de l'autre et qui permet
justement tout un travail entre les les
élèves mais également
les associations de pouvoir en fait
aborder ces questions là de pouvoir y
travailler
voir également les sanctions qui sont
encourues lorsque il y à ce genre de
comportement inacceptable et je crois
que c'est essentiel dès le plus jeune
âge de là encore de pouvoir à la fois
sensibiliser mais également de pouvoir
avoir une réelle prise de conscience
chez chez les plus jeunes pour éviter ce
genre de comportement mais également
pour pouvoir les les dénoncer parce que
c'est effectivement en libérant la
parole et en pouvant en témoigner que l'
on luttera tous ensemble collectivement
contre des comportements qui n'ont plus
lieu d'être une question de julien de
nice êtes vous favorable aux quotas
favorisant la parité en politique ou
plus largement dans les milieux
professionnels valérie oui alors merci
julien
alors ça c'est une question qui avec la
pour laquelle j'ai un peu de mal à
répondre
quelque part j'aurais tendance à dire
oui c'est bien d'avoir mis des quotas
nous l'avons vu dans les élections
municipales les départementales les
listes aux régionales c'est bien mais
quelque part une femme qui n'a pas envie
de s'investir
on ne peut pas la pousser alors c'est un
peu paradoxal parce qu'on a mis des
quotas pour qu'ils aient des femmes dans
bien des communes petites communes en
zone rurale on a du mal à les trouver
des femmes qui veulent s'investir mais
on est obligé d'aller en trouver parce
que on est obligé d'en avoir sur les
listes alors voilà on le fait mais d'un
autre côté souvent voyez nous les
parlementaires on est encore en nombre
insuffisant au niveau des femmes
mais toutes les femmes ne souhaitent pas
s'investir en politique on l'a dit tout
à l'heure c'est lourd il faut concilier
sa vie professionnelle si on veut garder
une vie professionnelle
sa vie de femme sa vie de maman souvent
une femme jeune lorsqu'elle élèvent des
enfants petit elle va pas pouvoir partir
tous les soirs faire des réunions pour
sa commune pour son département à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat à
partir de trois jours par semaine c'est
très compliqué donc c'est aussi les
femmes qui doivent manifester cet
intérêt
se dire voilà j'y vais je me lance et
puis quelque part ma vie va changer je
ne serai moins souvent à la maison ça va
impliquer des choses différentes pour ma
famille voilà toutes les femmes ne
peuvent pas le faire ne souhaite pas le
faire donc
est-ce qu'on a dû s que c'était bien
d'instaurer ces quotas eh bien je repose
la question parce que je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas si c'est bien de l'avoir
fait ou pas moi je souhaite que les
femmes qui ont envie de s'investir le
fasse spontanément et qui est pas
quelque part une obligation de quotas à
respecter
voilà ça c'est très personnel avec son
moi réagir essayer de répondre à ta
question
moi je pense que les quotas sont
indispensables puisqu'on voit en fait là
où il n'y a pas de quotas il n'y a pas
de femmes donc c'est malheureux de
devoir se voir imposer des quotas mais
si on n'y passe pas c'est vérifiable à
100% donc il ne s'agit pas de forcer des
femmes à s'engager en politique je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes qui ont
envie de se lancer il faut juste choisir
et leur donner une place dans le milieu
d'entreprise c'est pareil il y a dix ans
il ya une loi copé zimmermann qui a
imposé 40% de femmes dans les conseils
d'administration des entreprises du cac
40 aujourd'hui on fête les dix ans de
cette voie cette loi là aussi s'il n'y
avait pas eu cette loi on n'en serait
pas là aujourd'hui donc malheureusement
il faut passer par ces lois et il faut
surtout qu'elle évolue il faut parvenir
à plus de parité dans nos deux chambres
alors c'est plus compliqué à mettre en
place parce que le système fait que
voilà mais il faut y réfléchir et en
tout cas c'est quand même une bonne
chose c'est que à chaque élection il ya
de plus en plus de femmes donc déjà
c'est une avancée elles ont toute leur
place et donc il faut continuer à
imposer des quotas
clairement je suis favorable aux quotas
parce que on a été longtemps la lanterne
rouge de l'europe on était dans l'est
dans les bas de classement
et bien sûr on préférerait un idéal que
les femmes soient spontanément choisies
qu'elles soient à parité de nombre avec
les hommes mais on sait très bien que
dans la vraie vie ça ne se passe pas
comme ça donc je pense que le les quotas
l'exigence de la parité
et tout simplement une exigence de
justice et ça à faire avancer les choses
ça nous a fait gagner 20 ans peut-être
donc beaucoup d'entre nous ne serait pas
là sans la loi de la parité et je pense
que c'est une bonne chose que ça pose
les questions que valérie a posé je les
entends parfaitement
elles ont été posées au moment de la loi
sur la parité
elle était légitime mais il faut voir le
résultat aujourd'hui les femmes prennent
leur place dans les conseils
d'administration des grandes entreprises
pas encore dans les posters
responsabilités donc le chemin n'est pas
totalement aboutie
elles prennent toute leur place dans
tous les autres mandats le corollaire de
ça et c'est peut-être une chose à
laquelle à mon avis il faudra porter une
grande attention dans les années qui
viennent c'est que il faut aussi que le
rythme de la vie professionnelle et leur
rythme de la vie électorale ou élective
s'adapte à la vie des femmes parce que
les femmes elles veulent aussi pouvoir
tout en exerçant une vie professionnelle
accomplie une vie élective accompli
elles veulent pouvoir continuer de
s'occuper de leurs enfants en bas âge
par exemple ça c'est un vrai sujet dans
certains pays du nord n'y a pas de
réunion au delà de 18 heures c'est
totalement étranger à notre mode de
fonctionnement
mais c'est sans doute une chose à
laquelle nous devrions réfléchir pour
une meilleure conciliation de toutes les
vies de femmes et de famille parce que
les hommes sont aussi leur mot à dire
dans cette affaire
il propose qu'on passe à un sujet
différent si vous avez au fond répondu y
compris sur la place des femmes en
politique mais également dans
l'entreprise et cette question c'est
celle du port du voile dans les lieux
publics c'est une question d'henri
dechatre qui s'interrogent quelle est la
position des républicains sur la
question du port du voile dans l'espace
public qui est une question de féminisme
au delà même de la question républicaine
à nîmes oui c'est une question dont on a
beaucoup débattu tout récemment avec la
loi principes de la république
moi je le dis d'emblée je n'ai jamais vu
dans le vent
la signe d'émancipation où l'expression
d'une liberté féminine je pense que les
d'ailleurs dans les préceptes de la
religion musulmane il n'est dit nulle
part que la femme doit être voilée parce
qu'en réalité le voile il est fait pour
cacher la femme au regard des hommes
donc c'est à la fois dévalorisant pour
les femmes que l'on prive d'une forme de
liberté mais c'est aussi dévalorisant
pour les hommes qui sont réduits au
regard qu'ils peuvent avoir au regard
malsain qu'ils peuvent avoir sur les
femmes donc je vois ce que j'aurai dira
en préambule deuxièmement lorsque l'on
voit que dans notre pays on voit le des
fillettes de deux petites filles cela
cela nous choque profondément parce que
il y à là l'installation dès l'enfance
du cygne d'une d'une sujétion de la
femme à l'homme ce qui est absolument
contraire aux principes qui régissent
notre vie sociale et qui régissent la
civilité entre les hommes et les femmes
les hommes et les femmes doivent se
respecter sans que pour autant on
dissimule les uns les unes aux autres
donc nous nous sommes beaucoup battus
parce que clairement pour la plupart des
républicains je ne vais pas dire
peut-être pour tous les républicains
mais autant que je puisse en juger pour
l'immense majorité d'entre eux
le voile n'est pas n'est pas ainsi
d'émancipation c'est un signe de
sujétion ce n'est pas un signe de
liberté c'est un signe d'aliénation et
je crois vraiment que cette question
doit être clairement posée le voile
n'est pas conforme à la tradition qui
qui existe dans les relations entre les
hommes et les femmes de notre pays
merci beaucoup annie on poursuit avec
une question de marie-jeanne de colombes
que compte faire notre party les
républicains pour améliorer le nombre de
femmes candidates aux élections
législatives a laissé aller à y répondre
c'est effectivement une une question qui
enlève le masque j'ai pas pris le
réflexe d'enlever le masque c'est
effectivement une question sur laquelle
notre parti se penchent d'ores et déjà
on sait à quel point les élections
législatives
et là en l'occurrence de 2022 se prépare
et s'anticipe et c'est en cela que
notamment le président de notre
mouvement christian jacob mais également
le président de la commission nationale
d'investiture
eric ciotti ont justement rappelé est
écrit aux différents présidents de
fédérations pour justement prendre cet
engagement d'une nécessaire parité dans
les circonscriptions à reconquérir pour
notre famille politique en 2022 et je
pense que c'est essentiel que nous
soyons aux côtés des femmes qui
souhaitent s'engager que nous leur
donnions aussi l'envi de pouvoir
finalement s'autoriser à franchir le pas
de cette vie politique et finalement
tout l'accompagnement qui est nécessaire
pour toutes les raisons que l'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure parce que c'est
pas facile que finalement le déclic est
pas automatique et que finalement je
crois profondément à cela la la force
des réseaux
le fait aussi de pouvoir s'entraider le
fait de pouvoir c'est paul et sa
compagne et est nécessaire et c'est
finalement tout le message aussi que
l'on délivre c'est d'être aux côtés de
nos futurs de nos futures candidates et
de pouvoir en faire en sorte
effectivement que ce soit une réalité
aux prochaines élections législatives
sélective en 2022 merci à l'aise à une
question
l'avant dernière question de blandine de
villeneuve-lès-avignon comment
promouvoir l'égalité des droits entre
les femmes et les hommes sans tomber
dans le piège de l'égalitarisme et
commencent à y répondre sur la question
des quotas tout à l'heure avec la fois
vos convictions et vos interrogations
valérie sur ce sujet évidemment il faut
que chacun puisse développer selon ses
compétences
un homme une femme on est
complémentaires on se respecte on
travaille dans le même sens pour faire
évoluer x domaine je pense que tomber
dans le piège de l'égalitarisme serait
vraiment un vrai piège pour le coup
parce que nous ne sommes pas les égales
des hommes et les hommes ne sont pas les
égaux des femmes chacun a ses
compétences
chacun sait faire des choses dans son
domaine et je pense qu en se respectant
par exemple dans la vie politique
eh bien on pourrait davantage les femmes
pourraient davantage trouvé leur place
c'est une façon de travailler ensemble
de s'écouter de se respecter et de
grandir ensemble voilà on ne doit pas se
dire je suis l'égal d'un homme je suis
meilleur qu'un homme où les hommes ne
doivent pas se dire mais cette femme
qu'est ce qu'elle est nul c'est une
femme qui elle sera mieux derrière son
fourneau dans sa cuisine
voilà c'est du respect du travail des
compétences de l'intelligence tout
samian dans le bon sens et je pense
qu'on peut y arriver sans essayer de
rivaliser avec un homme ou une femme
selon ce qu'on est voilà on poursuit
avec la question de valérie delon vic
quelles sont les mesures innovantes et
inspirante en faveur des femmes que nous
pourrions retrouver dans un projet
présidentiel soutenues par les
républicains et par celui ou celle qui
sera notre candidat a ni moi je crois
qu'il ya tout un pan a continué travail
est d'ailleurs notre famille politique a
ouvert la voie à montrer le chemin
lorsque christian jacob et ministre de
la famille il a mis en place la prime
d'accueil du jeune enfant pour permettre
aux femmes
de continuer leur vie professionnelle
moi je crois qu'il ya tout un champ à
investir et nous n'en sommes à mon avis
qu'au début pour permettre aux femmes de
d'exercer des responsabilités
professionnelles de travailler et d'être
également présente autant qu'elles le
souhaitent dans la vie de famille dans
l'éducation des enfants
moi je suis convaincu que lorsqu'on voit
tous les désordres aujourd'hui d'une
jeunesse complètement déboussolé et
parfois d'une violence extrême de ne
pouvons pas ne pas nous interroger sur
les défaillances des familles il faut
permettre aux enfants et aux parents
d'être présent les uns aux autres
peut-être davantage qu'ils ne le sont
aujourd'hui et pour ça il faut permettre
aux femmes notamment d'être davantage
dans la conciliation de leur vie
professionnelle et de leur vie familiale
on n'a pas achever ce travail là il ya
encore des femmes qui ont des rythmes de
vie impossible inferno qui courent toute
la journée qu'ils récupèrent des enfants
des heures tardives qui les laisse le
matin des heurts beaucoup trop précoce
donc il ya tout ce travail à faire et je
pense que c'est quelque chose dont
devrait s'emparer à la fois les
syndicats professionnels et syndicats
partout que patronaux les syndicats de
salariés
c'est un travail à faire ensemble parce
que
clairement notre pays n'est pas un
modèle du genre
et là encore les pays du nord souvent
nous montre la voie en étant beaucoup
plus respectueux des rythmes de vie des
uns et des autres voilà un champ que
j'aimerais que notre famille politique
investisse pleinement pour être dans le
concret parce que notre famille
politique n'est pas dans l'incantation
de l'égalité réelle comme disent nous
et les élus de la majorité les membres
du gouvernement nous avons toujours être
tout notre parcours politique aux
républicains montrent à quel point notre
famille politique s'est investie
concrètement pour la cause des femmes
vous pouvez reprendre depuis la loi ne
vire sur la contraception en passant par
la loi veil sur l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse jusqu'à la loi
pradier sur la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
nous sommes vraiment dans le concret des
mesures et dans l'efficacité des mesures
et je crois que là nous avons des
preuves à donner merci beaucoup à nice
que je vous propose pour pour conclure
et à vendre avant de noter c'est que
chacune d'entre vous soyez en mesure de
nous dire justement qu'elle pourrait
être un des grands combats en faveur des
femmes que notre famille politique
aurait apporté dans les mois qui
viennent on y vient d'ouvrir un champ
très important et je vous pose que
chacune vous puissiez nos fils et un
objectif commun objectif pour les femmes
mais aussi un objectif pour notre
famille politique et pour l'idée que
l'on se fait de notre pays et de la
république elsa je rejoins totalement
l'idée dany de d'être vraiment dans ces
temps de conciliation de la vie
professionnelle et de la vie familiale
car c'est un élément qui est essentiel
et si on n'apporte pas de solution à
cette question de la conciliation à
travers notamment une autre modification
une refonte notamment du congé parental
avec une meilleure prise en compte
également des droits des pères parce que
ça passe également par là on passera à
côté des débats et des débats qui
reviendront en fait cycliquement et on
le voit sur cette nécessité d'avoir à la
fois une conciliation mais pour avoir
une meilleure
finalement un meilleur épanouissement
dans la sphère familiale mais également
dans la sphère dans la sphère
professionnelle
et puis après c'est bien évidemment de
pouvoir aller encore plus loin et de
lutter contre dans la lutte contre les
violences sexuelles ou là aussi c'est un
combat de l'ensemble de notre famille
politique et des parlementaires
mais on voit encore malheureusement dans
l'actualité des faits toujours plus
grave intolérable et là aussi à travers
l'arsenal législatives il me semble
important de pouvoir apporter des
solutions
oui alors il y a trois thématiques
majeures on en parlait ce soir c'est
bien sûr une meilleure représentativité
des femmes on a parlé dans l'entreprise
ou dans la politique
annie genevard à l'instant et ma
collègue elsa schalk ont abordé aussi le
sujet évidemment de l'accompagnement des
familles c'est important dans le travail
aussi une femme aujourd'hui il faut
savoir que la plupart du temps elle
craint d'annoncer à sa direction qu'elle
est enceinte elle craint de devoir
demander un congé parental allongé c'est
pas normal au 21e siècle en arriver là
donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment
travailler à des à des politiques qu'ils
puissent mieux accompagner et mieux
valoriser c'est formidable d'avoir un
projet de fonder une famille elle doit
pas être empêché par une culpabilité
aujourd'hui que vivent à mon sens
beaucoup trop de femmes la question des
violences sexuelles
bien sûr avec aurélien pradié qui a au
sein de notre famille politique fait un
énorme pas en avant en mieux protégeant
les femmes victimes du volant c'est
intolérable aujourd'hui d'entendre le
nombre de féminicide qu'ont lieu chaque
année les chiffres progressent était
terrible donc il faut renforcer encore
cet arsenal mais nous avons déjà engagé
le débat
voilà sur cette thématique et puis faut
pas oublier que on va tristement fêter
l'anniversaire de cette pandémie qui a
fait plonger beaucoup de femmes de
familles monoparentales dans la
précarité là aussi je crois qu'il faut
avoir comme projet des moyens
nécessaires des actions concrètes là
aussi pour mieux accompagner toutes ces
familles monoparentales toutes ces
femmes qui sont tombés dans la précarité
aujourd'hui en étant une élue locale on
est souvent sollicité par nos
administrés pour des places en crèche
d'accord mais beaucoup pour des
logements sociaux on se rend compte
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que 100 %
de la population aujourd'hui demandent
un accès au logement social ça veut dire
qu'il ya une vraie précarité qui a été
malheureusement accentuée par la
pandémie donc c'est un sujet majeur que
nous sommes en train de de relever nous
sommes de travail depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire au sein de notre
famille politique et ce sera l'occasion
pour le projet présidentiel dans d'en
décrire les dispositifs
alors pour ma part je pense que les
femmes ont leur rôle à jouer évidemment
dans leur vie dans la vie
professionnelle et dans leur vie
politique à condition d'être entendu
d'être écouté aussi par le grand public
et d'obtenir la confiance du grand
public parce que comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure
les femmes ont un manque de confiance en
elle et c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on a
dû instaurer justement cette loi sur les
quotas en politique
quelque part le public doit aussi faire
confiance aux femmes les écouter les
apprécier voir la façon dont elles font
pas leur activité professionnelle leur
activité politique est vraiment leur
donner toute leur confiance parce que
souvent je l'observent moi lorsqu'on est
souvent vous savez
sur une tribune il ya plus souvent une
femme et quatre hommes qu'un homme et
quatre femmes je vous assure en
politique c'est souvent comme ça donc
malheureusement à notre pays ait fait
cette façon là les femmes doivent
batailler un peu plus que les hommes
mais il faut aussi qu'elles obtiennent
la confiance de leurs concitoyens après
il faut quand même respecter le fait que
dans notre société judéo-chrétienne
allait elle est comme ça ce sont les
femmes souvent qu'ils élèvent leurs
enfants
donc la société doit permettre à une
femme dans sa vie professionnelle de
pouvoir élever ses enfants tu le disais
tout à l'heure annoncée une grossesse à
son employeur lorsqu'on a un métier à
grande responsabilité
on réfléchit à deux fois c'est pas
toujours facile on retard de l'âge des
grossesses
on les fait plutôt vers 35 ans lorsqu'on
a une grande responsabilité c'est vrai
que c'est quand même quelque chose qui
existe dans notre pays malheureusement
donc en politique c'est pareil
voilà j'ai un enfant j'ai un mandat je
vais faire comment faut que j'accouche
rapidement pour revenir aux commandes
très très vite
tout ça c'est pas encore dans les moeurs
et il faut qu'on évolue le que les
mentalités dans notre pays évolue là
dessus une femme fait des enfants mais
peut aussi être compétente en politique
et dans la vie professionnelle
alors moi je terminerai par l'expression
d'un souhait
on n'a jamais autant parlé d'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes et je
trouve que les relations n'ont jamais
été aussi difficile pour certaines
femmes pour certaines jeunes filles dans
le milieu scolaire dans leur quartier où
elles sont souvent malmené où elles sont
souvent dévalorisé et je m'inquiète moi
de la difficulté que les filles les
jeunes filles et les femmes ont à se
faire respecter dans certains milieux où
les violences verbales ou les agressions
n'ont pas
non non pas diminuer loin s'en faut je
trouve que je pense que c'est un travail
considérable que nous avons à faire en
matière d'éducation
mais il nous faut réapprendre le respect
des femmes
réapprendre aux garçons à respecter les
filles réapprendre aux hommes à
respecter femme il me semble que la
situation s'est plutôt dégradée bien
qu'on parle de plus en plus souvent
d'égalité donc voilà c'est j'ouvre le
termine ce tour de table sur une note
qui n'est pas forcément très positive
mais qui est plutôt un appel parce que
je crois qu'il ya des phénomènes de
société contre lesquelles nous avons
nous responsables politiques le devoir
impérieux de lutter merci à toutes les
quatre merci à chacune et chacun d'entre
vous de nous avoir suivis merci annie
merci valérie merci alexandra merci elsa
à la fois de vos témoignages et plus de
l'exemple que vous donnez à notre
famille politique mais je pense aussi à
tous celles et ceux qui ont pu nous nous
écouter j'étais très heureux d'être en
minorité ce soir autour de vous et
encore merci de nous avoir suivis et
merci pour vos contributions
à très bientôt